За одну хвилину в джунглях зникає чотири з половиною футбольних поля прадавніх лісів.
І це лише в Бразилії. Світовий лісовий фонд стрімко зменшується,
за останні 30 років була знищена десята частина лісів.
Ліс для нас життєво важливий. Він стримує підвищення температури, виробляє кисень
і зв'язує шкідливий для клімату CO2.
Змішані ліси, в яких господарюють правильно, забезпечують нас деревиною,
створюють добробут та робочі місця.
Ось так народжуються ліси.
Мільйони дубових саджанців, із зимовим листям, закопують у землю.
Пройдуть роки, і тут буде діброва.
Однак у мене виникає запитання. А чи можливо це, знову залісити Землю?
Я хочу з'ясувати це. 10 років тому представники різних країн зустрілися в Бонні
і заснували кампанію "Боннський виклик".
Вони вирішили відновити ліси та засадити пустирі.
Кожна країна поставила власні цілі.
До 2020 року вони хотіли посадити 1,5 мільйона квадратних кілометрів дерев.
Але цей проєкт виявився надто амбіційним та гігантським:
засаджена територія мала б розмір як пів індійського субконтиненту.
А за наступні 10 років вони хотіли залісити ще 3,5 мільйона квадратних кілометрів.
Територію, яка була б більшою за всю Індію, зникла б під зеленим дахом.
Це найбільш амбіційна у світовій історії програма відновлення лісів.
У ній беруть участь держави по всьому світу.
У Перу в Андах, а також у багатьох африканських країнах.
В Індії, а також в Пакистані.
Чого досягла програма до цього моменту?
Я зв’язався з представником Лісової служби Руанди.
Ми відновили не менше 900 000 гектарів лісу.
З цим ми майже пройшли половину шляху.
У Боннському виклику беруть участь і такі країни як Малаві.
Там теж посадили нові дерева, але загальний підсумок є негативним.
Оскільки в інших місцях країни дерева продовжують вирубувати.
Ми хотіли відновити ліси на 4,5 мільйона гектарів.
Райони - це рілля, заповідні ліси, державні ліси та прибережні смуги, майже скрізь.
Але у вас був зрештою плюс чи мінус?
Мінус. Остання статистика, яку я бачила, показує, що ми втрачаємо
39 000 гектарів щороку, але ми садимо лише 24 000 гектарів,
тому, на жаль, це знову не врівноважується.
У підсумку Боннський виклик зміг лише уповільнити вирубування лісів.
Тому глобальний лісовий покрив все ще різко знижується.
За останнє десятиліття було вирублено 470 тисяч квадратних кілометрів.
Ця територія більша за Швейцарію.
Багато експертів вже вважають, що мету Боннського виклику не досягнути.
Як це бачить сама організація?
Це трагічно. Лише відновлення лісу проблеми не вирішує.
Потрібно дбати і про збереження лісів. Ми завжди казали, що це не можна ігнорувати.
Німеччина не взяла на себе жодних квот у Боннському виклику.
Зрештою, 30 відсотків країни тут і так вже покрито лісом.
Однак це переважно монокультури.
Ось чому лісівники підсаджують скрізь нові змішані ліси:
Змішаний ліс набагато стійкіший до шкідників, до кліматичних негараздів
і набагато цінніший для всієї екосистеми. Адже тут набагато більше видів,
він набагато кращий для відновлення підземних вод, стану гумусу,
балансу поживних речовин, а також є грошовим гаманцем власнику лісу.
Змішані ліси означають більше роботи,
але і дохід від комерційної деревини в них більший.
Більшість країн, що дбають про лісорозведення, саме про такі мріють.
Багато країн все ще відстають від своїх цілей,
однак справу вже започатковано.